- Hi, I'm Renee Zellweger,
and this is how I became
Judy for the movie "Judy."
(horn music blaring)
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
I started in the car with
Judy and my imagination,
in the passenger seat, and
my laughter and embarrassment
at contorting my body and howling,
trying to make these
sounds come out of my face
for the first time ever.
Her music playing all the
time, or her interviews.
I was always listening to her voice,
and anything I could get my
hands on, just to feel like
we were conjuring the essence of her.
I loved watching her with Mickey Rooney
on her television show.
You could see her charm.
You could see what a sweet
friend she would've been.
You see how smart she was.
Funny, just so funny.
And you have to be so
smart to be that funny.
I loved watching her performances
on "The Judy Garland Show."
When she sang, especially "The
Battle Hymn of the Republic,"
when her friend, President
Kennedy, was assassinated,
she sang that song as a tribute to him.
It's a gorgeous
representation of the power
of her ability to emote through her voice
in a way that will touch you,
I mean for keeps, very special.
- Your suite has been released.
- What do you mean released?
Where exactly has it gone? (chuckles)
The clothes were fitted
to an assumed posture,
so they didn't zip up in
the back unless I stood
like I was supposed to stand,
so it was really helpful
if I ever got lazy, the
dress would not let me forget
what I was supposed to be doing.
Very helpful to be disciplined
by antique sequins,
so that was a pretty
big part of feeling like
you're just a little bit closer
to a representation of the lady.
♪ And the dreams that you dare to dream ♪
♪ Really do come true. ♪
It was this collaborative
series of experiments,
just trying things.
It started with, "Come on
over, and we'll just try
"a couple of looks, and
we'll try some recordings
"just to see where we are,
and where we might get to."
And then, we started
trying some dance moves,
and trying some clothes, and
we just kept trying things
until here we are. (laughs softly)
I think I remember the first time I heard
"Come Rain or Come
Shine," I started laughing
(laughs heartily) 'cause
I felt like somebody lied.
They moved the goal posts.
You know, they said, "Here, try and do
"this vocal performance,"
where, you know, she really
was having difficulty
accessing her instrument.
And then, they sent that
recording. (laughs heartily)
I'm still laughing.
And then, working with Matt, thankfully,
who was our extraordinarily
talented composer,
and Jeff, who's a music producer,
and Andrew, who was playing
piano and doing warmups,
and Paul, who were all
there for all of it,
and just making it feel possible.
"We'll do it again, let's do it again.
"Okay, no one more
time, we'll do it again,
"we'll do it again.
"Okay, 10 more times, we'll do it again.
"Okay, now you have to stop
'cause "you won't talk tomorrow, so stop."
And when it came time to
do the actual performances,
I felt like I had my stage
moms (laughs) off to the side
going, "Yes you can, it's gonna be fine,
"it's gonna be fine."
And I'm sure they were all
like, (sighs and laughs),
but anyway, in this moment,
I would love to say thanks to those guys
'cause it's not possible
without all of them,
and Rupert and David and everybody around.
It was a team effort, for sure.
You won't forget me, will you?
(applauding)
♪ In a moment ♪
Promise you won't.
(applauding and cheering)
(warm orchestral chord)